happy comic on day three this is gonna
be my breakdown of the spider-man
homecoming footage is just an
explanation for what they showed off a
comic-con that they're not gonna post
online at least for a long long time so
like I just posted the spider-man panel
the director came out with the actors
with Tom Holland he did his Civil War
line where he's like hey everyone and
then they kind of explained thematically
what the movies meant to be how they
engineered it to fit in with all these
other big Marvel movies is like you know
piscine billionaire genius
philanthropist Playboy's but we haven't
seen the story of a young Spider mate
like a young kid in the Marvel Universe
trying to make sense of all these new
things so the footage that they brought
like the teaser trailer just shows a day
in the life of Peter Parker sophomore in
high school with typical
sixteen-year-old kid problems that just
happened to be taking place in a world
with the Avengers so a lot of it took
place at his high school he kept having
to find reasons to slip away to do
spider-man things like a problem comes
up he needs to stop being Peter Parker
he's like okay time to hero up put the
suit on go kick some butt buddy but he's
still stuck in high school so he can't
let everyone know that he's spider-man
so he has to find creative ways to sneak
around there was a brief vulture
sequence they did confirm that vulture
is gonna be the big bat of the film
meaning that that's Michael Keaton's
character Michael Keaton is the big bat
of the film the vulture is the big
character but we also learned that the
Tinker like a younger version of the
Tinker played by this actor in shocker
will also be in the movie and is it to
reiterate that this is taking place in
the world of The Avengers like this you
know post Captain America Civil War
timeline this is taking place after
Captain America Civil War there's a
group of girls playing a game action I'm
gonna custer real quick I'm gonna drop
an f-bomb real quick just for the sake
of this so there's a group of girls at
Peter's school playing that marry
kill game with different Marvel
characters that we've seen in movies
before so just a really funny way to
show you what real high schoolers would
be doing inside the Marvel Universe
right now like we see what the Avengers
do when they're chilling out like they
all take turns trying to lift Thor's
hammer you know it's like a really fun
game well what would someone at Peter
Parker's high school be doing like
they'd also be playing a version of that
but it'd be marry kill with the
Avengers characters so it's just a very
John Hughes type wink at the Marvel
Universe and if you don't know who John
Hughes is and you don't know why
everyone's referencing him so much when
they're talking about spider-man
homecoming he's the guy that made Ferris
Bueller's Day Off Breakfast Club
weird science which Robert Downey jr.
started when he was really young Sixteen
Candles pretty in pink so he just made
some of the best high school movies of
all time he wrote and directed really
amazing stories about high school kids
so that should give you an idea of how
they're making this spider-man film and
how it's gonna be different from the
other Marvel films but also how it's
going to tie in and also another big
thing to tie it to the Marvel Universe
is that the vultures flight suit is
supposedly made out of our e-tec
that was left after the Battle of New
York so I think I've mentioned it before
in videos but this is so much a marvel
fit like you wouldn't think spider-man
because you're so used to thinking of it
as a Sony franchise and yet Sony still
owns the character but look they're
presenting this at the Marvel panel it
is so much a Marvel film creatively
they're in control of the character they
got to pick the actors they wanted they
got to pick the story that they wanted
so if you're talking to any of your
friends about spider-man and they're
confused about whether or not Marvel got
spider-man back yes they did technically
but Sony still has a financial interest
in the character so imagine Marvel's
making this movie and they're just
sharing the profits with Sony but there
was a whole bunch of other footage that
they showed off that they're not gonna
allow to be online like there was a thor
ragnarok funny documentary they shot
they've only been filming that movie for
five days but they basically filmed an
episode of The Office with Thor in the
Hulk to explain what they were you know
quote-unquote what they were doing
during civil war so what I'm gonna do
next is a Doctor Strange trailer
breakdown then I'll do a guardians of
the galaxy to video for the footage they
showed off they confirmed whose star
Lords father was
he's ego the Living Planet we even got a
look at his costume so I'll do a video
for that just explaining what the
footage was and what the movies gonna be
about James Gunn explained a whole bunch
of stuff and we found out who Captain
Marvel is it's gonna be brie Larson they
finally confirmed it she was just like
surprise then she ran on stage
and got super surprised by Benedict
Cumberbatch it's so funny to watch some
of these big Marvel characters some of
whom who have won Oscars fangirl on some
of the other Avengers characters so
that'll all post later today and I'll
say congratulations to this round of the
giveaway Geordi salcedo you had a $20
Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
is a new round of the giveaway that's
starting now there's still so much Comic
Con stuff happening so it'll be much
more Marvel but more DC stuff that I'll
be posting for the
couple of days so like I'll try to get
it out as fast as possible but it was a
lot of fun I was really happy with Comic
Con this year while you guys wait for me
to post that you can click here to watch
the spider-man panel again and you can
click here to watch the flash season 3
trailer thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight